if you had to go up against hundreds of
psychotic killers in Crazy death games
what would you do you'll need to figure
out how to survive and go against your
opponent your friends and even your own
mind and the only way to win will be by
using a harmless fishing rod fighter
pilot brain tactics and stealing secrets
that David goggin himself uses in order
to help us beat these death games and
become more badass I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the hunter exam of
Hunter Hunter this doad kid is going to
go up against thousands of opponents and
fight 405 of them in countless
psychological and physical death games
all designed to break the human soul
sounds like a great time anyways gone
here is the son of an absent I will I
mean missing father anyways he wants to
become the world's greatest hunter
Legendary Heroes who risk their lives to
seek Treasures monsters and Superstar
Fame just like lots of people nowadays
so this kid wants to try out for this
year's team he wants to sign up and join
and he manages to catch this town's
biggest and most dangerous fish in 20
years holy smokes that's huge moving on
he secures a spot for the hunter Tri out
making his caretaker Aunt M here nervous
as hell because well she's hiding a dark
secret I would think so with that face
she's making anyways she allows him to
go but decides to finally to confess to
him that his abs missing father didn't
just run off to buy milk but he's
actually a hunter and he's been too busy
being a badass stud to come back to
check on his family definitely a message
you want to tell the kids at home Bon
thinks that means being a hunter is the
coolest job in the world and leaves his
aunt Meo to become a hunter immediately
and he wonders what all the exams and
trouts will be like but he has no idea
that the test has already begun sailing
through a crazy storm he joins other
potential Hunter candidates and all Happ
to get a case of seasickness all except
him and these other two guys kopika and
Leorio getting CAU into the Captain's
Room he asks them why they all want to
become Hunter badasses gone answers
without a Caren world and says just
wants to be like his loser I mean super
cool role model Hunter father okay so he
gives his answers but these other two
don't answer and give the captain a hard
time pissing him off and he warns them
if they don't play by his rules they're
all going to fail right now which by the
way has already started so the captain
tells them that thousands try out to be
hun Hunters each year but most fail and
die in over 7 billion ways and I'm going
to reveal the math behind that in a
little bit this Captain here and people
like him screen out rookies who clearly
aren't ready for the test and then he
lands another truth bomb on them
everybody who got seasick has already
been disqualified from the hunter triout
so with so much on the line karaba
finally gives in and reveals why he is
the last surviving member of the
mysterious CTA Clan he wants to brutally
Slaughter the gang responsible for the
death of his people the Phantom troop
and the really nasty group of people
that he's actually going to face a whole
lot sooner than he thinks but Oreo here
he keeps it simple and says he's in it
for the Benjamins because being a hunter
is the most well-paying job out there
but then Kaba takes exception to this
and he starts arguing with Lorio but
whose reason is better but then suddenly
a massive wave slams into the ship
screams and shock fill the area and this
sailor nearly Falls overboard but gone
rushes to save him and his kind heart
forces these two to stop arguing and
work together to help him in his dumb
butt and now the captain's been
impressed by their skill and teamwork
and he tells them they've passed the
first test and will be allowed to
continue on their journey to become
become a hunter okay I'm not sure if I
should be thanking this guy or should
maybe reconsider my uh decision because
like there is no telling what to expect
coming up within the next three phases
however there is one fun little hack
that I would use if I wasn't as slick or
as cool as gone I would actually use
this trick to increase my chances of
winning every competition by an
additional
9.75 million per. at least that's how
amazing I think this hack is going to be
let me explain look for starters gone
here should have expected a ton of
sneaky tricks like this from the get-go
because Hunter tests happen every year
and each time they are full of different
tricks monsters double Crossings and
death games wink and even if they knew
what to expect we wouldn't know when
they would happen and this means just
like that one friend of yours with a
degree that he doesn't know how to use
knowledge is only useful to the degree
that it can be drawn on when needed
however there is one simple way that
regular non luuy people like us could
have used if we were to go into this
situation gone should have used
something known as the ace framework
which is a framework that American
fighter pilots used to simplify
strategize and figure out Dynamic
problems on the Fly and they can also be
used for literally like you need to
assess the problem first we know that
the main thing we need to make through
is these exams which means we need to
make good decisions more often than not
despite not knowing what to expect which
is a problem so from knowing the problem
to choosing a possible solution that
would help us minimize the negative
outcome for example we don't know when
the test will show up but we can
minimize all of that potential problems
ifs and maybe if we execute one thing
and this one thing would be by using
Common Sense logic and by looking at the
biggest clue of the hunter exam their
dropout rate if we look at the Navy
Seals entrance exam the entrance exam
costs about 350 to 500,000 to fund one
single Navy SEAL just for them to join
but imagine how many people try and fail
to join the seals within their first
week alone and how much the military
would have to spend paying for everybody
who joined the boot camp the trick is
psych they don't not with their 75 to
80% dropout rate this Hunter exam is no
different they only want to spend money
and train the best who have potential
and would try to get out as many
applicants as they can as early as
possible which means we need to be on
our game because everything here is a a
test so the captain drops them off at
their next location and the captain says
to take this road towards the highest
tree and taking this mysterious path
will help them arrive at the next exam
faster not revealing At All by the way
that this is still a test but Leorio
thinks it's a little suspicious because
according to the map the tree here in
the distance is the complete opposite
way from where the exam should be ending
up there anyway they pass through this
town and bump into this old lady who
quizzes them before they continue their
Journey luckily tra manages to figure
out that this is a trick question and
the group barely manages to pass the
test to the next round getting way more
lucky than others who have already died
trying to reach this point in the exam
so they head to the real location of the
exam site and they encountered this cute
little cabin in a nice open green area
but it's really anything but because
they spot this injured guy he tells him
that his wife has just been kidnapped by
bloodthirsty monsters he sets them off
on another wild goose chase to go rescue
her until they find out that this was
another test these people are actually
Hunter Navigators and they tell them
they passed the final mini test and will
take them to the actual location of the
first test anyways they drop them off at
this restaurant which is actually a
secret Hunter location and they take the
secret lift deep underground to floor
100 and on the way down kabo cautiously
warns them about the Hunter Survival
stats that is going to make them all
poop their pants only one rookie every
three years makes it through and most
break down from all sorts of traumatic
horse even if they survive arriving in
this dark tunnel hundreds of other
applicants are all about to be put
through hell and then you got this weird
guy named TOA who hands them a number to
wear on their chest and tells them this
is his 35th attempt for the hunter
triout which SS the whole group here but
in doing so and makes them miss this
guy's biggest red flags he warns them of
some of the players they're going to go
up against and points them all out
Master Killers expert psychos Olden
Goldies all dying to join the most
lethal hunting force in the world and
there's a whole bunch of them you got
Toto the wrestler bourbon the Snake
Charmer bodoro the martial arts master
you got the three brothers and you got
this one Fedora lady I don't remember
her name she's not that important but
then suddenly they hear the piercing
screams of this one guy getting killed
and he disappears off the face of the
Earth and then they spot the most badass
opponent of all Koka the magician he was
supposed to become a hunter last year
but he nearly killed the hunter examiner
because the examiner pissed the guy off
Tampa warns them that they would let s
himself join the hunters if he was good
enough and he tells them they need to
stay away from people like him but
problem he put laxatives inside of them
he hopes to make them poop their brains
out so bad they fail the test a gon's
freaking super sensitive taste buds warn
him that it has expired and stops the
others from drinking as well the nervous
Tomo quickly apologizes and then leaves
to plot his next move when they least
expect it but then he comes across one
of this group's most lethal applicants
this kid number 99 kilua he comes back
smiling asking for one more pooper soda
all because he's been trained to handle
all types of poyson anyways he smirks at
TAA and says that he's the coldest
killer of all of them but that's when a
hunter examiner with the coolest
mustache in anime appears examiner satos
and he gives them a rundown of what's
about to happen the first phase of the
official hunter games is about to begin
only one in 10,000 people have made it
here so far with 404 applicants
remaining he starts walking and
everybody follows him and casually says
they're headed to location of the second
phase of the exam and they think he
misspoke but then he starts picking up
the pace and he reveals that well
they've already begun the first phase
the Battle of endurance here's the rules
one the got to follow him and also they
don't know how long well you know this
next challenge seems simple enough I
would actually rely on two really simple
great worldclass mental techniques that
would help us guarantee that we win this
thing with one being highly toxic and
not recommended for the general public
let me explain the next challenge is
called a ruck march commonly used in the
military for its physical and
psychological team building benefits but
mentally that is the purpose of this
phase of the exam as Mike Tyson once
said the mine makes the fighter so much
better than he actually is and it makes
super a lot of sense because just like
on the ship it's clear they want
Warriors of the mind and we could have
known this in advance if we had analyzed
the United States Seal ethos I know I
know I'm in a real seal mood today but
the cool and the point of it it actually
contains Clues as to what we need to win
this competition cuz if you look closely
you'll see a theme Here perseverance
thrive on adversity never give up
discipline and attention to detail this
is what the hunter exams want from us it
means everything else is a distraction
well it might seem intimidating to
compete if for just regular people there
is something that you could do that
would give you an edge look not being
told when the exam will end has already
got our brain trying to figure out the
problem whether we want to or not this
is going to make her mind drain its
energy faster and on top of this
performing mentally demanding tasks in
general makes you tired it makes you
lose motivation you just want to lie
down and cry maybe just me which is why
if I had to do this thing I would use
two very simple mental model techniques
that anybody can easily use in order to
become a David goggin's machine number
one I would make the goal of becoming a
hunter almost religious really dive deep
into my feels you know to help build the
epicness of the goal in my head cuz it's
going to give more meaning to me to help
me achieve my goal like for example I
will cure cancer if I achieve this
that's how epic I need to trick my mind
into thinking this goal of ours is
number two the second technique that is
super Toxic by the way and one that you
should only use in very small amounts
I'm very serious is by relying on
toxicity over the goal of winning this
competition itself in order to mentally
never give up these four things for
example passion purpose Joy fulfillment
are less likely to keep me motivated to
achieve my goal during highest times of
stress which is why we need to dig deep
within ourselves and rely on something
really palpable something that you can
hold on to something evil and possibly
toxic actually something very similar to
the Beast himself David gogin actually
uses and how he does it is by
essentially reverse psychology ourselves
in the most harmful way possible
remember this is only going to be used
for short term when it really counts by
reframing our goals to focus more on the
negative over the positive in this case
we don't want to become a hunter we want
to fear not ending up like a loser who
might as well kick a bucket the only way
for this to not happen is to become a
hunter using these two mental methods
can be the simplest and fastest way that
anybody can get the Iron Will to never
give in in anime or in real life hours
passed by 80 km deep and people start
dropping like flies but thankfully gone
makes a new friend with Kila and he
finds out he wanted to become a hunter
because he's bored not revealing the
true reason oh and Lorio finds his inner
strength by taking off his shirt moving
on a little later the main Heroes and
the remaining applicants each reach
phase two of the hunter exam and the
losers get their dreams crushed forever
and sat hultz welcomes them to their
next location the mly wetlands and he
takes note who has left 36 examinees
down 368 more to go the next location's
dangers are announced bloodthirsty
animals known for tricking their prey
humans into becoming dinner and scotes
warns them that they must stay behind
them as they continue the journey and
must not fall for any traps just because
they're well there's a lot of them and
also this that require brains as well as
Bronze in order to survive this
contestant comes out of nowhere and
warns everyone that Sato here is not the
real examiner he's actually a flesh
eating monster in Disguise pulling out
this monkey that looks just like him the
group begins to argue about who to trust
but Hoka decides to test the powers of
both of them and kills the impostor who
isn't skilled enough to block his attack
revealing satos to be the real examiner
proving in a very lethal way who the
real top candidate is and most dangerous
one satos then uses this moment to teach
everyone a lesson if they get lost or
injured no one will be able to reach
help or save them and everyone looks at
the thick fog around this swamp this
part of the phase is brutal separating
the men from the boys that's right some
boys are just going to hold out much
better than some men here unlike some of
these badasses most of us are just weebs
like us and this means we know what
Horrors we're about to face I would
first take into account our weapons and
what do we got using his fishing rod I
would use some of the line off of it and
use it to wrap around the hands of the
group as a sort of a safety line I know
what you're thinking by tying a safety
line around everyone's waist it would
actually be kind of risky what if
something comes at us and we need to
separate I understand but you know this
is a risk reward type of assessment and
on average most fishing poles have at
least 125 yards of line which means
we'll still have plenty to do all sorts
of cool attack with it if we need to you
know grab stuff lasso people swing
around Spider-Man style take somebody's
eye out because while the swamp is a big
threat it's not actually the biggest one
here because just like lady ABI and
princess monoke I'm more worried about
the humans around me satos just told us
to stay behind him but knowing all these
tests are designed to get rid of the
weak don't you think it's logical to
assume that those who sip through all of
this mess are actually going to be super
dangerous Cutthroat strong people which
means if we keep up with them we're
going to be really close to these scary
killers who are way more dangerous than
anything here that is why before signing
off I would look for the man that we met
ear earlier TAA well yes he is
definitely a slee ball he is our SLE
ball I'm kidding but he is a veteran
test taker in the beginning proved to us
how much he knew about everybody
bringing him along would allow us to get
in real time data who was all near us
while we follow close behind satos if
we're close to the instructor we can use
TOA to our advantage because if he did
one of us or all of us could immediately
punch him in his big fat mouth that
being said while this test might seem
doable this group right here is soon
going to realize that uh just like the
first test the boat nothing is as it
seems okay so the gang sets off but the
group begins to immediately split apart
it's amazing how quickly it happens
Leorio and kopa fall behind from gone
and Kila and they stay put for now since
there are too many people ahead of them
low visibility problems start to quickly
swallow up even the toughest candidates
and just then the heads of these people
in front of these two start disappearing
and then suddenly their next flesh
eating opponent reveals its ugly head
and starts going off on everybody around
them eating tons of Japanese men harder
than a jab production dozens of
applicants around start getting royally
screwed by what Mother Nature has to
offer even Birds impersonating sat's
voice more and more people quickly get
sent in the wrong direction into into
their doom and the whole group gets
quickly isolated running for their lives
Leorio and corop haul butt and run into
the one thing worse than Mother Nature
herself hea killing all of these guys
with a freaking pencil just like John
Wick I'm kidding I had to say he
actually killed him with a Magik cart
but that's when he spots his next Target
and Kaba warns the Oro that this guy is
way too powerful for them and convinces
him to run but Leorio is more cool guy
than smart guy and swings around
thinking his ego can help him beat
hisoka he quickly gets destroyed and
gone finally shows up separated from the
main group and quickly distracts isoka
with his fishing rod and that was his
biggest success Hoka notices the gone
actually manages to surprise him and Lio
tries to help out and the two tag team
but quickly get defeated in minutes
coming up and choking gone he
suspiciously lets him go at the last
minute revealing that he can sense
future potential in him and Loro as well
and tells him that he passed his test
and then he gets notified that the
survivors are reaching the next phase
picking up Leorio now unconscious he
tells gone that he'll see him at the
next phase leaving gone more shocked
than thankful that he survived another
day he meets up with the Lost Kaba as
gon's group unlike most officially make
it to the second phase of the hunter
exam that makes 220 down with only 148
more to go and they reached their next
phase at the Visa Forest Preserve and
here they meet their next Hunter
examiners meni and buhara they are
Gourmet Hunters Gourmet Hunters are
warriors that specialize in gathering
highlevel ingredients and cook Gordon
ramsy quality style meats and they give
everyone their next test is not what you
think it involves pigs and cooking well
the contestants laugh in disbelief at
the assignment and they think this task
is going to be easy and they're stupid
they head off and sure enough they find
the pigs devouring a plate of human
bones so they run for their sweet lives
and these wannabe hot dogs brutally
Crush dozens of contestants with their
super strong cute noses using them as
Shields to block any attack in the
middle of the chaos gone quickly spots
some apples knocking out a pig and
realizes that it's forehead is its
weakness and after that everybody sees
what Gan just figured out and sure
enough everybody brings back some pigs
and begin cooking but this Gourmet
Hunter Chef is a real hard ass thinks
they all suck at cooking and fills
everybody on the spot watching them from
the distance sat's called calls up the
hunter exam chairman and alerts him that
meni hear is back to her old crazy ways
again chairman Neto then comes down to
sort this problem out and tells her that
they need to pass some of these
applicants or else the entire Hunter R
and this video will end right here she
apologizes and offers to give them all
another test and will also join them to
prove herself and now up next their new
test is going to be over here up at
Split Mountain they got to capture the
Egg of the spider Eagle AKA dream eggs
down in the canyon floating 10,000 ft
above the ground and on top of that they
got to deal with horrifying winds meni
shows them how it's done she proves her
Hunter skills and grabs an egg right
before she catches some Canyon wind and
flies back up and lands safely but a few
chosen do jump down and try to copy her
and they hang for their lives and this
one guy jumps down and grabs an egg
first but then ends up falling to his
death confused Go and Kill will spot the
critical mistake and warn everybody else
that they got a wait for the canyon wind
to blow in their Direction then they can
jump down waiting for the signal gone
takes charge and uses his sensitive nose
to detect an incoming wind like a
freaking blood hound and that's when the
spider rope begins breaking and
everybody realizes that he can't hold
them for long and now all all eyes are
on gone for the signal before it's too
late the impatient ones start jumping
out early and but a few ballsy ones wait
for gone wondering if this kid will be
the death of them hate to say this group
might seem like badasses but they're
actually really stupid they could have
passed this exam way less risky
stressfree and easier first off don't
jump straight to your death because this
was their opportunity to learn from
others mistakes like the first guy by
waiting for others to jump they could
have gained valuable Insight on what to
expect down there by watching other
rookies test it out first you know you
ever tried jumping into a small pool
with your friends at all at the same
time it's a nightmare and everybody
bumps into each other and the same risks
could have been applied here except by
bumping into each other it would have
meant certain death or at the very least
missing a shot of grabbing an egg by
waiting we would have avoided the big
crowded bum rush all at the same time
and also could have just walked up to
the ledge first to see where the eggs
were and then jumped in in closer
proximity to the egg cuz remember none
of these tests are what they seem they
were never given a timer to complete
this test which means we didn't have to
rush like idiots it gives them the
signal to drop and they catch the
remaining few eggs and fly back out
passing the next test and take a victory
bite out of their eggs unaware that like
justtin King's game the upcoming tests
are going to get more impossible that
makes 362 down 42 more to go with no
time to waste everybody heads off into
this balloon to the third and final phas
of the exam led by the boss man himself
chairman nro he tells them that they can
rest till morning when they reach the
next location gone and Kila rush off to
explore the ship while kopika and Lorio
hear some more sweet lies from TAA he
warns them that the third phase might
already be happening that this is all a
test and he urges these two to stay on
alert the whole night just in case
secretly trying to make them drain their
energy before tomorrow meanwhile the
hunter examinees discuss who they think
has the most potential to win the hunter
competition and they voice their
concerns about the group's biggest wild
card Hoka because his love for death and
blood is like nothing that any of them
have ever seen meni here mentions his
evil energy was creeping her out during
the cooking test and this made her
irrational about her test in the first
place and they agree to keep a closer
watch on him from now on elsewhere
chairman nro runs into gone and kilwa
but consents that kilwa doesn't trust
him and he offers to play a game with
the boys if they win he'll make them
both official Hunters immediately so the
game game is ball tag if the two boys
conceal the ball from his legendary hand
they win kilwell warns the old man that
he comes from a family of Assassins and
he shows off some moves from Mom and Dad
before attempting to steal but sure
enough every time he gets outsmarted and
gone Subs in to help but also gets
defeated however chairman nro notices
their great potential a little later on
another part of the ship TOA checks in
on Leorio and kopa but sees them
sleeping like babies pissing him off
that his plan has failed but he doesn't
know that his time to shine is soon
going to come all right so everybody
reaches the next sight of the third
phase their next challenge reach the
base of this Tower alive within the time
limit this one cocky applicant then
mentions that he used to be a rock
climber and he quickly scales down the
building but then they hear a siren Call
of something really scary getting close
Airborne Killers fly past the man hungry
for his blood and they rip him to pieces
and devour him whole a little later CA
notices almost half of all the other
applicants have disappeared from the top
everyone then notices five hidden trap
doors and assume that the other
applicants have found more doors like
them but each one can only be opened
once it can only fit one person in each
so they each agreed to take one but all
land in the same room anyways and then
spot some rules on the wall stating that
five people who enter this room must
cooperate in order to escape there are
several ways to clear the tower but each
way can only be taken if the majority
agrees on a decision given these timers
they realize they don't have much time
left needing a fifth person to show up
they wait and sure enough somebody drops
in The Lovable loser Tampa getting ready
the game gives them a preview of how to
play Everybody Must agree on a shape and
click the same one on their watches
everybody except Tampa clicks on one
shape and the RO gets pissed off but TOA
showes him that he was just the harm
mistake and next time he won't cost them
the real game they head to the next room
for the next task and ask them which
direction they want to go half the group
picks both options and Kaba tells them
that according to science practicology
people tend to unconsciously go left
when they're feeling lost which means
they might have a better chance of
winning if they go right following
kaba's suggestion they run into this
massive Atrium with these really creepy
prisoners and the tower Warden then
announces on the loudspeaker that these
are the prisoners of the Tower and
they've been hired by the hunter exam
committee to test their skills here's
the rules they must each fight all of
the prisoners one-on-one and each person
can only battle once victories win an
opponent and Miss defeat and they can
pick which order they fight in the team
with majority of rounds one wins but
here's the deal for every hour a
prisoner keeps gon's team inside the
arena one year will be reduced from
their sentence so they ain't going to go
easy on them they have 72 hours till
they have to escape this prisoner steps
up as their first opponent ready to do
whatever it takes but too suspiciously
offers to fight first just to test out
the waters entering the prisoner states
that this is a death match and Tom
agrees to the terms then cue the badass
music but old guy charges a Tampa rated
kill just as Tampa gives up before the
fight even begins everybody including
the bad guy looks in confusion and
meeting defeat the prisoners win the
first round and Lorio gets really mad
but Tampa finally reveals who he is he's
not here to pass the hunter exam he's
here to mess with others and ruin their
dreams of becoming hunters and now he's
developed some sort of psychological
getting off on it so he's a freak Leorio
loses his and the others try to
calm him down because they still need to
work together and take on the next
opponent soken given a 149e sentence and
he's a Serial bomber and gone offers to
take him on on next the skinny prisoner
offers to play a game based purely on
luck each one will choose two candles
and whoever candles burns out first
loses pretty simple unable to tell which
one to pick the group lets gone decide
and he goes for the longer one they
light up their candles and the game
begins a strong draft to win suddenly
rushes past them and now they must
concentrate and not move an inch and
just then gon's candle starts bursting
in Flames melting Faster by the second
The Prisoner reveals he prepared four
candles and tampered with all of them so
he would have lost anyways Thinking Fast
gone realizes his candle flame is
burning too fast to go out using this
opportunity he puts his candle down and
rushes over to his opponent blowing his
candle out and cleverly wins the game
next up this guy given a 100e sentence
multiple crimes including fraud and
blackmail and he fights against kopa
showing his tattoos representing the
people he's killed and he warns him that
kopa is going to be his 20th victim the
game it's a death match blood guts and
pain how fun the rules until one of them
dies or gives up no weapons just fists
but kopa sees a tattoo on his back and
it's a very special tattoo a 12 legged
spider this guy belongs to the Phantom
troop and kup cases this and boy he
freaks out his eyes turn blood red and
he rushes him grabbing him and gives him
the beat down of his life and he tells
him that he knows that tattoo of his
mortal enemy is fake because it lacks a
serial number and he says if he ever
says their name again he'll kill him
assuming he won eyes have now gone back
to normal and he gets a little nervous
and tells his friends that when he saw
the spider he lost control and this by
the way includes seeing real spiders his
personality shifts into something
horrifying and everybody freaks out
including the Oreo meanwhile hisaka
passes the trick Tower's third phase in
6 hours and 7 minutes with one more win
left to go this mysterious prisoner
walks forward forward but tells gon's
group some upsetting news she announces
that kic's fight isn't over because his
opponent isn't dead but it's just passed
out since it was a death match and no
one gave up this round isn't over
ashamed of his rage earlier Kaba this
time refuses to kill him which means
they got to wait until his opponent
wakes up group votes on it but majority
votes to wait pissing Loro off and
breaking the group dynamic now realizing
that this was a part of all of their
slimy PL a little while later after
waiting gone suggests something that if
it's true would be insanely sneaky he
suspects that kab's opponent died a long
time ago forcing L Roo to ask the the
prisoners if they can go look for
themselves but the mysterious prisoner
offers them a gamble with her on whether
or not this guy is alive suspiciously
ready she rattles off the rules as Loro
and her get locked into a match the
rules they will bet each time but can
only use 10 hours as a bet each time
they Gamble and must keep betting until
one of them runs out of time if leroo
loses this battle his whole team will
have 50 hours less time to escape the
tower if the prisoners loose they will
serve another 50 years of jail Kaba
warns Leorio if they lose they will have
less than 9 hours to escape this Tower
Leorio then accepts the match and Bets
10 hours going up and finding out that
this guy is in fact still alive causing
this group to instantly lose 10 hours
next up kwood thinks the prisoners are
secretly keeping this guy alive but
unconscious Lio bets next if this guy's
really passed out or not but this girl
pulls a fast one and Bets 20 years
against leorio's guest however in order
to check if he's really playing dead
Leorio comes up with an idea carrying
him to the edge and threatening to drop
him the fear of dying surprisingly
causes the guy stops pretending and runs
away making Lorio win this bet and he
tells the girl that he could tell this
prisoner was alive based on the movement
of his eyes cuz he actually wants to be
a the doctor long story not important so
he thinks I'm doing pretty good right
now I'm a smart cookie I'm going to win
this thing for my team this prisoner's
cuffs and clothes finally come off larut
the Oro gets too excited by what he sees
and she then tells him that if he wants
to bet she's a man or a woman and to
prove if he's right or wrong she'll
allow him to examine her TSA style as in
however he likes and he immediately bets
10 hours that she's a man like a pervert
Kaba and Kil agree by the way just so
you know he goes to confirm it and makes
him excited that for once he lost the
bet watching Toma tells gon's team that
loral will lose his opponent already saw
through how he bets based on his way of
answering questions she knows he places
and chooses his bets based on whichever
one has the least damage and was caught
asking her the outcome of losing too
much making his desire to not lose much
greater than his desire to win and that
mindset will never win him anything okay
so we have a problem and we have to rely
on a hoing idiot to do it great
fortunately this is actually really
simple to fix and it would increase
leorio's chances of winning but not
doing nothing I know isn't that great I
love doing nothing let me explain I love
Leorio but right now he's not playing to
win well this may seem like a small
silly thing it's really not because the
psychological difference in your mind is
huge playing to win is choosing to dream
big instead of preparing for the worst
thing but it doesn't mean that you're
ignorant to the worst case either
because coming from a positive outlook
will affect yours and leorio's actions
right now in this moment and it makes
sense because in the moment the past and
the future don't apply they don't matter
all that matters is your Relentless
action in the moment what you do now and
coming from a place of not wanting to
lose will 100% negatively affect your
actions in the moment because of this
let me show you how this works a study
was done in Princeton undergrads two
groups of students were given the same
test with the same questions but under
different context one was presented as
being used to see if they truly belonged
at Princeton University under a threat
context the other was made to seem like
a challenging questionnaire under a
challenge context and the questions were
made to seem like brain teasers the
shocking result showed the students
operating under a threat context got
only 72% of the questions right while
students operating from a challenging
context got more than 90% right same
questions different perspectives when
you play it win aggressiveness
proactiveness and not out of fear you
understand mistakes will be made and
it's a part of the process but when
you're playing to lose Reckless and
reactive you get scared to make a
mistake and you're not willing to take
risks now loral here may not or may be
able to win by choosing to focus on
relying on a more positive realistic and
confident angle that will help him
operate in the moment more effectively
and to the best of his abilities while
not letting his own emotions in the
moment destroy any chance he has of
succeeding in the future which is a
skill you know we could all learn more a
little bit about the Oro plays right
into to his opponent's hand looking at
the clock he now has 10 hours left
if he loses this the group will be
defeated and will lose 50 hours gone
then suggests a final game of rock paper
scissors since Lio has experience in
this and that's when the prisoner
suddenly bets a whopping 80 hours that
she will win the first rock paper
scissor round which confuses him and he
realizes that even if he loses he'll
still only lose 10 hours and wonders why
she is betting such a higher number
causing him to get nervous and confused
as to what move to make watching this
kopa fills in the group on leora's odds
of winning telling him that you now have
a one and three chance of losing but if
your opponent manages to control your
thoughts the chances of losing increase
dramatically and like magic it's like
she hears K and she messes with Leorio
more and more and states that she can
read mind leio doesn't buy it and says
she could have won already if that were
true but she tells him that maybe she
let him win after all buying much time
is a method to win too much confusion
she suddenly plays her hand forcing
Leorio to play as well and they both
play Rock karaba tells gone what happen
is horrible when someone is nervous they
subconsciously avoid making moves with
their palms open it means that as long
as the Oreo is nervous he will never
play paper and play rock with rock will
result in a draw she wants him to play
rock or paper which does what buying
time and also could let her win and just
like that da team loses 100 to nothing
oh that hurts two wins two defeats and
now they got subtracted 50 hours ouch
and they now have less than 10 hours
left the final opponent approaches the
ring but he's not just any bad guy
Leorio recognizes him and warns the
others he's brutally murdered men women
and even children which means according
to anime villain logic he's the
johannas the dissector this guy tells
kilua that he's about to rip him to
shreds and he doesn't care about being
released and just gets super happy about
consuming The Souls of Innocents and
drinking their blood and blah blah blah
but Kila says cool and blast the hall
right through his chest and Kila is
holding this poor douchebag's heart
right in front of him and wins the match
without breaking a sweat he reveals to
the group that my dad is way more cool
and makes gone secretly realized that
maybe everybody powerful as balls has a
father complex deep down now with this
death match over the game then instructs
them to head into this room and wait to
spend the 50 hours that they just lost
meanwhile daddy H sooka breezes through
to the end of the third phase and
becomes the first winner great with
others lagging behind as time passes 5
hours later the group busts out kicking
and screaming and running like a madman
taking all sorts of crazy roads they
come across a final door saying that all
five can go through this longer and much
harder path or three of them can take
the shorter easier one the game urges
them to fight to the death in the side
but gone comes up with an idea opening
up the door with the longer path he
instructs the group to break down the
wall leading to the Shor one making his
gang even top arrive just in time to
finish the third phase of the hunter
hunter exam with 25 finalists left the
group walks out with pride not knowing
which friends today might be their
enemies tomorrow and they get ready for
the next even more horrifying hunter
test that is headed their way but what
do you guys think about the video don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
thumbs up down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist